with the DC swamp we're a very angry and
very confused bewildered Nancy Pelosi
continues inexplicably
to cling on to her BS articles of
impeachment I have a message for
Republican senators coming up first
let's watch Nancy no definitely I'll
send them over when I'm ready and that
will probably be soon I don't you know
you said if you don't send them over I'm
going to pass the mexico-us my
candidates trade agreement okay but no
we we want to see what they're willing
to do and the manner in which they will
do it but we will not let them say oh
this is just like Clinton's fair is here
it's not documents documentation
witnesses facts truth that's what
they're afraid of okay
anyway speaker name only Pelosi has now
been sitting on the articles for over
three weeks now these are the very same
articles the Democrats they were clean
this is urgent the nation is at risk
time-sensitive a matter of imminent
national concern
Pelosi rammed through the house and
record time only one fact witness rest
for just well here say an opinion
witnesses Democrats and in subpoena any
of the key witnesses because according
to them the country couldn't afford to
wait for a court decision now for weeks
they've been telling we you the American
people nothing has ever been more urgent
ever they took a right up to Christmas
till they went on vacation the future of
our country was at stake take a look I
do expect that the Judiciary Committee
is prepared to move very quickly the
president based on with his past
performance will do everything he can to
make it not a fair election and that is
part of what gives us the urgency to
proceed with this impeachment the timing
is really driven by the urgency and that
is national security issue yes a
national security issue an issue of our
election integrity this is not a rush to
judgment it's a rush to justice yeah but
then we gotta go on vacation first then
we're gonna take our time and then we're
gonna second-guess it okay Pelosi has
now pause this super important super
urgent process indefinitely it is the
kind of level of hypocrisy outright
dishonesty and lying that is
unconscionable but it is very fitting
Democrats with the help of of course
their best friends and the media of mob
state-run TV the deep state had been
lying to you to us every step of the way
first we have the compromised corrupt
congenital liar
the pencil-neck I guess the president
calls him Adam Schiff lying about the
transcript of the call between the
president and president Solinsky next
shift lied about the fake non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower
remember he said his office they would
they would like to have contact I'd like
to hear from them he had no contact with
the individual when in fact his office
was in fact communicating with the
hearsay non whistleblower whistleblower
even before he filed the bogus complaint
next Democrats lied about witness
testimony during the shift show the
first audition show the secret
closed-door witness rehearsal show
Democrats selectively were leaking only
the misleading information in order to
impugn the president and gain public
favor
that's called propaganda ultimately they
passed two boldest articles or the only
one fact witness one that's it
ambassador Sandlin whose testimony was
exculpatory for the president he wanted
nothing no quid no pro no quote like Joe
I want nothing the preceding was a
dishonest train wreck from the very
beginning to deceive the American people
and lie to get the support of the
American people there was never any
evidence it was non-existent now there
is for quid pro quo Joe and zero
experience hunter well you're not
getting the billion unless you fire the
prosecutor investigating my zero
experience son yeah the very thing they
act so outraged about there was no due
process like Newt Gingrich afforded Bill
Clinton in his attorneys in ninety eight
nine no basic fairness no
my crimes no misdemeanors no bribery no
treason one nebulus abuse of power
charge whatever that is one totally
made-up obstruction of Congress because
this president dared to do what all the
presidents before him have done and that
is when they can't get along in the
executive and legislative branch you can
seek remedy you can go to the court
system they settle those disputes after
all they were in a rush this was urgent
now Pelosi has all the time in the world
apparently guess it's not as urgent as
they said another lie she's demanding
the Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell follow her strict instructions
for how the Senate trial should be run
she wants him to call all the witnesses
they didn't call but yet they impeached
him they failed to get the subpoena she
also wants to ensure a fair trial with
total impartiality big problem there is
her best friend or BFF in the Senate
Chuckie Schumer totally agrees but in
the 90s when a Democrat was being a
peach chuck was running on exonerating
Clinton 11 separate felonies can star
identify take a look this is not a
criminal trial but this is something
that the founding fathers decided to put
in a body that was susceptible to the
whims of politics and also it's not like
a jury box in the sense that people will
call us and lobby us you don't have
jurors call one lobbied and things like
that I mean it's it's quite different
than a drinking Oh Oh total hypocrite
get the theme here hypocrites liars zero
principles no core values selectively
feigned moral outrage and Chuckie
Schumer actually ran for the Senate on
that promise to acquit President Clinton
without any case being presented and
back then the Independent Star report
determined Clinton committed he
identified eleven specific impeachable
offensive including felonies Chuckie
Schumer raged against the mere prospect
of ever impeaching of a US president
over lying and suborning perjury and
perjury take a look if we vote articles
of impeachment I fear that we will be
setting a precedent that would could
seriously weaken the office of president
of the presidency whether the president
is removed from office or not
we will be in danger of all too
frequently investigating presidents and
seeking to remove them from office
unless a miracle occurs we will take one
of the most serious and rare actions
that this body can assume and impeach
the president against the overwhelming
will of the American people now we are
routinely using criminal accusations and
scandal to win the political battles and
ideological differences we cannot settle
at the ballot box history will show that
we've lowered the bar on impeachment so
much we have broken the seal on this
extremely extreme extreme penalty so
cavalierly that it will be used as a
routine tool to fight political battles
my fear is that when the Republican wins
the White House Democrats will demand
payback is there's no need to continue
forward because there are certainly not
two-thirds for impeachment we what we
ought to be doing instead of this is
doing what the American people want us
to do and Chucky's opinions course
conveniently magically evolved but many
of his Democratic colleagues in the
Senate they're growing pretty weary of
the spectacle and the outrage of Nancy
Pelosi speaker a name only in her stall
tactic and stunt Majority Leader
McConnell has consistently offered the
same rules and procedures that the
Senate approved for the trial of Bill
Clinton 100 to zero and now top
Democrats are asking Pelosi and the
charade that demanding it even senator
Feinstein fellow Californian saying it's
blow seize decision but if there's
serious and urgent send them over if it
isn't don't send it over
Democrats Doug Jones angus King Joe
Manchin Chris Murphy Richard Blumenthal
and Chris Coons and others all echoing
Feinstein's ultimatum even one House
member Adam Smith he he called for
Pelosi to stop stalling then he had to
recant probably after getting well
beaten down and closed doors
smoke-filled rooms by friends of the
speaker look at this poll whopping 58%
of Americans think Pelosi needs to send
the articles over that would be called
due process and fundamental
fairness of course don't expect it
tonight Pelosi still desperately
dragging this on and on and president
Trump he's taking it at a task pretty
entertaining way as well take a look by
the way did you say it did nothing wrong
they don't even know what the hell is
going on
in fact it's so weak she doesn't want to
put in the articles it's so weak they're
so pathetic they're so pathetic
now since claiming the gavel every major
action taken by Pelosi revolved around a
party's deranged psychosis desire to
smear slander to Smerch and hurt Donald
Trump that's all they've done for three
years
nothing for wiiu the people it's all
been one big continuous non-stop
never-ending political stunt lies
conspiracies slander force murchman the
non-binding unenforceable meaningless
War Powers Resolution that's the latest
example let me address all of you though
in the US Senate tonight all of you
Republican senators you do not and
should not ever lend any credibility to
this despicable corrupt shift show don't
do it because all you're doing is
hurting the American people in the
process let them do it you don't be a
part of it let the Democrats they they
okay they impeach the president your job
is to run the trial of course with the
Chief Justice presiding let them present
their case they even peach them let them
tell you why now I'd like to hear they
can bring in the one fact witness but
constitutionally they impeach and they
present their case to you they say they
have the evidence to impeach your
constitutional role you Republican
senators is the trial the Chief Justice
presides the only and one fact witness
bring them in just one everyone else is
an opinion hearsay witness rules of
evidence federal rules of evidence don't
allow hearsay evidence to be presented
make them show you why they impeach
Donald J Trump it is not your job
Republican senators or your
constitutional role to redo their sick
twisted corrupt investigation with no
due process now after the house
managers present the reasons their case
which why they impeach the president
bring in the one relevant fact witness
that they used so he can repeat
ambassador Solomon what he said or read
back you know to the house or just read
back the testimony and then you can vote
that's your job you don't have to do
their job they impeach them they're
gonna tell you why they're gonna present
their case it's not your job to fix
their screw up your Republican senators
are weak and timid if you give
credibility to this repulsive corrupt
political stunt you're as guilty as
shift neither and speaker name only
Pelosi they impeached let them show you
why when they fail spectacularly and
they already have and they will this
will end the madness in other words
Republican senators stand up for the
United States Constitution that is your
role that is your job